the fear of getting negative feedback is
the single biggest reason why people
don't share create and post more you're
afraid of what people who aren't chasing
their dreams down think of you and it's
preventing you from chasing your own
dreams down that needs to end so last
night on my twitch stream I had a woman
join me in the comments who was saying
I'm afraid of saying the wrong thing I'm
afraid of moving forward and taking
action like I need to because I'm afraid
of saying the wrong thing I'm afraid I'm
gonna get judged and this is a bucket a
lot of people fall into every time I
make a video I'm afraid of saying the
wrong thing every time I get on stage
I'm afraid I'm going to say the wrong
thing especially when it's a live format
I'm doing an interview or I'm on stage
or I'm helping somebody I'm always
afraid I'm going to say the wrong thing
because my number one fear is
disappointing people we know we're
capable of more we know we're capable of
helping I know I'm capable of helping
but because you're afraid of saying the
wrong thing because you're afraid of of
letting somebody down because you're
afraid of giving the wrong advice what
ends up happening is you don't do
anything you have your foot in the gas
and break at the same time so your tires
are spinning but you're not moving
anywhere and you have to learn to let go
of the break but you never stop start
because you're afraid of negative
feedback because you're afraid that
people won't like what you put out there
you can't let that fear run your life or
you'll never accomplish the big things
that you want me motivation watch your
top ten with belief Nation hey it's Nina
Carmichael and we made these videos
because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your
soup off more and you get that Push by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best my
husband Evan Carmichael and his top 10
rules for success
rule number two learn from different
people you will never achieve your goals
by listening to people who haven't done
it for themselves that sounds pretty
common sense but it's actually what most
people do chances are you're the most
ambitious person that you know you've
got the biggest dreams of the people
that you hang around with and if you
keep listening to the people who are too
afraid to chase down their dreams you're
gonna become one of them so one of my
favorite things to do is I love learning
different things from different people
there is no one person who can teach you
how to be you but you can pull different
things from different people to learn
how to be the best version of you that's
your entire goals how do I become me how
do I become the best of a Carmichael how
do you become the best you and that
comes from pulling and learning from
different people different things look
at the people behind me on my wall
everybody's here because of a different
story and in the middle is is me and my
parents I'm I'm eight or nine years old
in this picture my parents are above me
and I have this on my wall because my
parents taught me to believe in myself
they taught me that I'm Evan because
Shirley Carmichael I could do anything
that I've believe that I can and my
aspirations my dream what I love to do
is be able to learn how to be a father
like my father was to me so I've got
I've got a son I want to be a great
father to him like my father was to me
I've also got Steve Jobs up on my wall
right here right and and I love having
Steve Jobs on my wall because I want to
learn how to be a Visionary like Steve
Jobs I'm working like this every day my
computer's here and I got I got Steve
Jobs staring me down right every day
when I when I walk in and start working
he staring me down because I want to be
thinking bigger I want to be having a
big Vision big dream big goals like
Steve Jobs was I don't want to be a
Visionary like my father because he
isn't one and I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs because he wasn't
a very good one but I want to be the
best Heaven Carmichael by taking
something from Steve Jobs and something
from my dad and something from Kanye on
the far wall there and something from AP
giannini right something from Howard
chose I want to pull different things
from different people to help me become
the best man the mistake that we make is
we keep listening to people who haven't
done the thing that we want to do and
trusting their judgment I don't want to
take parenting advice from Steve Jobs
and I'm not going to take vision
building advice from my father right
with with total respect
there are things that you love about
your friends there's things that you can
learn from them and and you want to be
around them and that can make you better
amazing but if if you're sharing your
dreams and they haven't done anything
big and they don't have aspirations and
they don't want to go off and accomplish
anything huge themselves and they're too
afraid to chase down their ideas those
aren't the people who you need to be
listening to for advice
you need to surround yourself with
people who will push you who you aspire
to be like and who you want to learn
something from rule number three work
hard and smart too many people think
that the secret to success is just
waking up an hour earlier if you weren't
productive with the 16 hours that you
are awake what makes you think that by
adding a 17th hour when you are more
tired is actually going to make a
difference the problem is that you're
losing too much time during the day
we're gonna fix that in this video so
I'm constantly looking at how I can work
smarter I'm constantly looking at how I
can hack myself hack my schedule to get
more done be more productive be more
efficient and work towards building a
life that I want to continue to build
this week is actually a great example
I've made a change in my calendar this
week where I've always done different
things on different days where you know
money is my mentoring day and Tuesday is
my YouTube day and Wednesday's my
project day and Thursday is my interview
public facing day and Friday is my CEO
day and Saturday is my fun day and
Sunday is my family been day right and
that's been that's what happens every
day as long as I'm here in Toronto and
not you know speaking or on tour
somewhere
I made a shift where I was reading an
article over the weekend talking about
how some people are better in the
morning at being
in research mode in intellectual mode in
planning mode and better in the
afternoon add more creative mode uh
talking to people mode and I resonated
with that even when I make these videos
I've shifted over the past couple weeks
to making my videos in the afternoon I
find when I make my videos in the
afternoon I have more energy it's more
fun I look forward to it more anyway I
make a video in the morning I have to I
have to force myself to bring the energy
more so in the morning I'm less
energetic I'm less outgoing I'm less
willing to talk to people and I'll do it
if I need to but I'd much prefer doing
in the afternoon and so now I'm applying
that across all of my days as much as
possible so in the morning chunk I'm
spending my time doing planning and
researching and intellectual and data
Gathering and processing and in the
afternoon is when I'm spending my time
doing Instagram lives and making videos
and meetings and talking to people and
mentoring and that kind of stuff and so
it's a test it's an experiment
government that I'm going through right
now and so far I'm kind of liking it I
don't know if I'm going to make it
prescriptive yet and if I'm going to
apply to everything yet but so far I'm
really liking it and and I think that's
constantly the hack because hard work is
important you have to work hard hard
work though is just your ticket in it's
not enough just to work hard there's
lots of people who work hard but then
don't accomplish anything who don't ever
get their goals or dreams
there's people who just work smart and
and that's not the ticket either right
just working smart is not enough either
it's that combination of working really
hard but working on the right things
that move your business forward rule
number four find your purpose finding
your passion does not have to be hard
understanding what you should be doing
with your life and how you can be
serving other people is one of the
greatest gifts you can give not just
yourself but your family your community
the world around you but if you write it
off if you write off finding your
passion as being too difficult not
worthwhile too expensive too scary that
you can't do it then you cheat yourself
up that amazing gift and you will never
be happy we're gonna fix that in this
video so I wrote this book built to
serve and I did it because I was on my
tour last year when I hit 90 days 23
different cities and I went for a
different reason I I went on my tour
talking about how to build momentum in
your life in your business and what I
kept coming back with in every city was
how do I find my passion how do I find
my purpose how do I know what I'm
supposed to do with my life in every
city the same thing kept happening over
and over and over and over and over
again and so I don't think the right
thing to do is slam people for asking
the question of how do I find my passion
I think the better answer is to actually
give them a process to give people a
solution and it just blew my mind how
difficult people make it on themselves
and they feel like they need to meditate
for years they need to hire some super
expensive coach they feel like it's
hopeless and I'll never figure it out
because they look at the people around
them and you see well the people around
you haven't figured it out so how am I
going to figure it out and if your
parents haven't figured it out why are
you listening to them to help you figure
out your purpose and your passion what
you're supposed to do it doesn't have to
be that difficult and I started going
through this process with people when I
met them at my different groups and my
speaking gigs in each of the cities that
I went to and
the most memorable one was in San Jose
where I walk people through this process
of who I how and just the first question
was like Hey I don't know I don't know
what to do with my life I don't know how
to find my passion I mean walking
through the who I help process and then
that person started crying and and uh in
a in a great way like wow finally having
some clarity and then the rest of the Q
a basically was me doing the same thing
for the people who I have who I have who
I have who I have who I have who I have
and and now people have Clarity and
momentum where they didn't have it
before and so it's why I wrote the book
it's why I'm making videos like this
it's because I want to share the process
with you so that you can find your
Clarity you can find your passion you
can find your purpose and turn it into
something that builds a happy life for
you aim for the people around you for
the rest of your life it's one of the
most important thing if you figure this
out understand that this will never get
old
finding your passion finding your
purpose those two things will never get
old you'll love doing those things for
the rest of your life also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five push through the
ping you are capable of more I just want
to tell you to remind you that you are
capable of more that this struggle
that's in front of you right now that
seems all-encompassing and impossible to
overcome it's not your max you can
handle it because if this is your max
then you don't grow and you don't become
the person that you know you're capable
of becoming
this video will help so the most pain I
went through was when I was on my tour
last year when I broke my neck I broke
my neck I I fainted and and hit my head
on the wall and and broke my neck in two
spots I can press my spine I had a
concussion which I've never had in my
life before and I had to they put me in
a neck brace they put me in these and I
wore this one for
50 days or so in this one for 10 or
something like that it was 60 days of of
wearing something like this and only be
able to take it off for 10 minutes a day
that's it so I had to sleep in this I
had to I had to shower in this I had to
do my speaking gigs and this and you can
see I don't know if you can see this
duct tape on here because this one was
more comfortable than this one and so
like I really didn't want to break this
one but just from use right from having
it on all day long eventually it broke
and my wife taped it up and she wrote
here I love you get well soon love Nina
kind of like a cast anyway this is the
most painful thing that I had to go
through and the day I broke my neck I
was supposed to be doing my speaking gig
in in Colorado and we had to cancel that
because obviously I can't do it while
I'm in the hospital
but then came a really important time
what do I do next I don't know how long
a concussion lasts I don't know how I'm
gonna deal with the pain I haven't
really broken a bone in my body before
let alone two in my neck I didn't know
how safe it was to travel still do my
speaking gigs and the advice was rest
and go home you can't get on a plane
because of the compression but just just
drive home just rest and go home
and you know my agent wanted me to do it
the the doctors want me to do it like
I'm not gonna go home I don't want to go
home
this is my chance to show myself what
I'm made of this is my chance to see
what I can do I'll let me at least try
let me at least try and it's very rare
that we actually get pushed to our
limits like our actual limits you're
pushed to your physical limits and you
can't do anything more and so my initial
thought was well forget that I mean
let's just everybody who was supposed to
come let's just do something tomorrow
this is what I was thinking let's do
something tomorrow in our Airbnb and
just have them come over and I'll lie
down on the couch or the bed and they
can ask me questions
I'm here to give value guys I'm here to
help let's go helping entrepreneurs is
going to be healing for me and the
doctor's like yeah you can't do that
you've got a concussion you can't even
think clearly properly like that's never
gonna happen so I had to refund
everybody in Colorado and um and my next
stop was Kansas City and we drove to
Kansas City not too far away and I was
still feeling the massive pain from the
from the neck but still the concussion I
hadn't recovered from my concussion and
I didn't know how long it was going to
last and I made a video
for the people who bought tickets to
Kansas City canceling on them
and what I wanted to do was say hey I'm
here anyway I'll give you your money
back come to the hotel and I'll I'll
still talk to you for as long as I can
go
and it was the morning the day before in
the morning and I was making a video I
thought
I couldn't even finish making a video
I started getting dizzy halfway through
the video and so I I paused it and I
thought okay we should just we should
just cancel this like I I can't even get
through uh two minutes of making a video
and so I tried again at night and I got
through the video and I said you know
what I don't know how long I'm Gonna
Last tomorrow I already booked the hotel
you know I'm not it's not it's
non-refundable for me uh you guys
already booked your tickets you booked
the time off in your calendar I'm going
to refund you the money because I'm not
gonna be able to go for four hours like
I've been doing in each City but I'll go
for as long as I can
if you want to show up and and I'll try
to help
and I went for an hour and a half
and it was the greatest hour and a half
you know one of the greatest hour and a
halfs in my life and and my wife had to
then pull me off after an hour and a
half because I was starting to get I
didn't even notice it but I was starting
to get you know woozy on stage and um it
was great I was so pumped because this
was this was I'm done I've never been
pulled off a stage before
and here I was at my Max
and I love the idea of pushing through
the pain obviously be healthy obviously
don't be stupid
but a lot of times we pull ourselves
back way too soon we don't allow
ourselves to actually test what we're
made of to see how far we could actually
go
and so I kept these
thanks to my friend Mark Draeger I don't
collect things I don't I don't have
Souvenirs of stuff but he said you need
to collect you need to save them as a
souvenir of what happened as a Memento
like all right whatever I'll keep it and
I look at this I'm like I'm crazy I did
that
60 days in this and kept going on tour
and we still did 10 more cities and I I
sat at the front of these stages sitting
down because I couldn't stand properly
and I had had like two or three pillows
behind me in an ice pack over my right
shoulder the whole time and and still
spoke for three to four hours every day
right I still made videos you can go
back on my channel and you'll see me
wearing this with like this giant scab
or scar on my head because this is where
I hit my head on the wall
it's crazy this is a reminder of what
I'm capable of that whatever Max I feel
like I'm facing right now is not my Max
and I think you're capable of more as
well rule number six adjust your
calendar success equals habits if you
are not reaching the goals that you have
for your business and your life it's
because you are not doing the right
habits consistently I say consistently
because you are what you consistently do
not what you kind of do if you run a
kinda gotta do schedule then you're
gonna have a kinda okay life and a kind
of okay business I want to change that
in this video so I live by my calendar I
think it's one of the greatest tools you
can ever have that when you have
something that you want to accomplish in
your life in your business that it's in
your calendar because if it's not in
your calendar it just remains one of
these someday I will do something but
you never actually take action on it and
it's one of the biggest mistakes that
people make after getting inspired
motivated you watch a video like this
you go to a conference you listen to a
podcast like that was amazing so much
fire and you might be on fire for the
rest of the day but then you don't
follow through because it's not in your
calendar
show me your biggest goals in life and
business tell me what they are if I was
gonna charge a hundred thousand dollars
for for an hour of coaching with you
right this is what I would focus on what
are your big goals and show me in your
calendar where you are spending your
time for too many people they don't line
up for too many people they have these
Ambitions and great ideas but they just
State ideas and Ambitions because it's
never actually in your calendar and so
if you don't put the big things in your
calendar you'll never accomplish them
the little things will take over your
life for too many of us the little
things have taken over and it's not that
they're not important because they are
but small and importance and so you can
tell yourself I get I did so much look
at how much I did but then you look back
on the week it's like what did I
actually do I was busy the whole week
but did I move forward and my goals or
Ambitions probably not this is a problem
so for me I like having different things
on different days Tuesday I make videos
this is this is a Tuesday for me this
video may not be released on a Tuesday
but I'm recording it on a Tuesday
because Tuesday I am making YouTube
videos because I want to grow oh my
YouTube impact because I want to reach
500 million people a billion people
right I want to reach the world and I
think YouTube's the best way to do it
right now and so great it's amazing to
have that ambition show me in your
calendar where you're spending your time
well all day Tuesday I'm making videos
my project day Thursday is my public
facing interview day Friday is my CEO
day Saturday is my fun day with my wife
right it's this impacts your personal
life as well Saturday I'm I'm planning
the entire day for my wife that has fun
surprises where there's no work
happening not even going to Costco like
no Costco is not fun for me so we're not
going to Costco Sunday is family at
midday where that's Costco day that's
buy buy a new couch day that's do the
laundry day that's whatever needs to be
done for the family and then Monday is
mentoring day spending that with my team
right I look at my calendar and this is
what you can do look at your calendar
every week and see what's ahead for the
week is there a structure to it
if you looked at that calendar and
stepped above it and said if I did these
things will I move closer to
accomplishing my goals when I make
progress It's not that you're going to
hit your goal by just spending a week
working on something you won't but when
you make progress towards it is there
growth is there achievement happening
and too many people to know and I think
you should change that rule number seven
focus on the right things most
entrepreneurs spend way too much time
doing things that barely matter you're
working hard you're grinding every day
it's not that you're not trying it's
that you're spending your time doing
activities that are not moving the
business forward enough we need to play
bigger and focus on the right things
because you cannot be in the same spot
that you're in today one year from now
this video is gonna help so I've got a
friend of mine going through this right
now an entrepreneur she's she's an
amazing entrepreneur I want to see her
win so badly and and she has this very
clear path to what you need to do very
clear you have to do this you got to
talk to these people this will move the
ball forward this is all you need to be
spending your time on reach out to these
50 people and you will start to
accomplish success
and she's afraid she's afraid that she
doesn't have the answer she's afraid
that's not gonna work out she's afraid
they're not going to pick up the phone
she's afraid she's just afraid and so
she's consuming herself with busy work
she's consuming herself with tasks that
do move the ball but in tiny little
increments
that post into social media and that
touching base with someone in the team
and that logging into the CRM all these
things that probably should happen but
aren't really difference makers for her
business that's what she's spending her
time doing so she can Pat herself on the
back and say look at me I'm busy I'm
doing work I'm I'm crushing I went in
and I checked everything off my list
today except the thing that mattered
most
except the thing that will actually push
your business forward and everybody
around her this is likely a challenge
for you everybody around her
is looking to her as a leader is looking
at her as this ambitious go-getter
working hard person nobody around her
saying listen what you're spending your
time on is ridiculous is not where you
need to be put in your efforts and so
she's stuck in this in this plain small
mode in this land of excuses where yes
she's being massively productive but
she's not doing enough to move her
business forward and one year from now
she's gonna be in a similar spot
slightly ahead because she was too
afraid to take action on the things that
she needed to take action on
but now she's got me and I'm on her
every day to say how are we doing on
that list how are we doing on that list
how and suffocating the excuses because
I'm not buying the excuses because I
know she's capable of more because I'm
not gonna allow any out possible because
everybody in her life everybody in your
life might be letting you off the hook
thinking you're out there working hard
doing the right things but you are not
and you need either the self-discipline
to do it or somebody amazing in your
life to say I am not allowing you to
play small anymore
it's okay to be afraid it's not okay to
let that fear stop you because until you
start focusing on the things that will
actually grow your business forward you
will never accomplish the success that
you're after rule number eight step into
discomfort you are not that different
than your Heroes the people who you look
up to respect watch their videos of
listen to their podcasts read their
books there's not that big a Chasm
between who they are and who you are
there's a tendency to look at these
people have had ginormous success and
say Well they're just built differently
they're wired differently I'm not like
them and that mindset that way of
thinking for you to say that I'm just so
different from them is keeping you safe
and small and not realizing your
potential the only difference between
Your Heroes and you is the willingness
and ability to step into the discomfort
they were willing to do it you haven't
yet and we're gonna change it in this
video so on Monday I was meeting with
Alex who helps me run Toronto Dan salsa
and he's an amazing entrepreneur he's
got tons of heart and energy and love
and care and he's been struggling to
stay consistent he's he's working from
home right now we've got coronavirus you
know shut down lockdown he hasn't been
on his regular routine and I was pushing
him on Monday to get back on the routine
let's go basic things like clean up your
apartment and and make proper food for
yourself and stay on your workout
regimen this should be the time where
you stay disciplined and his response
was I'm not I'm not getting it I'm not
I'm not hearing I can't connect to the
advice because I feel like you're just
different than me
you just wired differently and that is
the biggest cop-out
because it allows you to play small it
allows you to look at people who who are
doing the thing it allows you to look at
me or Lisa or anybody who you look up to
right Steve or AP or Kanye or however
allows you to look at these people that
you love and respect and say well that
they were just so magical and so
different
and that's the reason why they won and I
I'm just never I'm not gonna be like
that because they're built differently
you're giving yourself an out you're
giving yourself the biggest excuse and
biggest out that most people fall into
that trap of and I told Alex dude there
is no difference between you and me not
on this the difference is my willingness
to step into discomfort my willingness
to say this thing is happy right now is
the greatest you're sitting there
thinking this is the hardest time of all
I'm thinking this is the greatest that's
the difference the mindset shift the
training that's got in to making that
mindset shift happens is the only
difference not that I'm better or born
different or have any other set of
circumstances that is preventing you
from winning like me and so I told him
this is a muscle that you built
starting today you start building that
muscle right I'm just a little bit
further ahead I've done more more work
in the weight room of of the mindset
right and so it's unfair to compare
where you write right now to where I'm
at and it's unfair to compare where
you're at you guys watch into where
Lisa's at or Steve Jobs or somebody else
because you're not comparing their
beginning and you might be at the
beginning right now and so it starts
today and I told Alec it starts today
what can you do today to make yourself
proud of your effort the problem is
you're not proud of your effort the
problem is you might be posting some
things to Instagram and saying look at
what I did today but you're going to
sleep at night you didn't pass the
pillow test saying you're proud of
yourself
what do you need to do today to be proud
of your effort
he said I gotta I gotta clean up my
condo because it's a giant mess like
great go clean up your condo
and it took him way longer than they
thought it was going to take but he did
it and then you know what magical things
happen he started making calls so the
people he needed to make calls to he
started making videos so the videos he
needed to make videos for he said to
have more energy and enthusiasm and and
hope and belief and confidence
because he did the difficult thing
now that's just one day it's every day
deciding to do that same thing over and
over and over and over and over again
and then that's how you build the muscle
you don't build giant muscles by going
to the gym once and working your face
off it's every single day going to the
gym rule number nine control your act
action when you have lost control of
your outcomes remember that you can
still control your actions you are not
in control of the market of your
customers of your Revenue but you can
still control how and where you spend
your time and if you're feeling
overwhelmed it's because you feel like
you have no control we're gonna fix that
in this video so as I'm recording this
video we're in the middle of the
chronovirus outbreak we're in quarantine
I'm here in my place in Toronto Canada
filming content like I normally do but
my business is hurting all the
businesses that I'm involved in are
hurting so if you look at my YouTube
channel as an example the views were
down the revenue rates on Advertising is
way down because people aren't
advertising right now my speaking
business is zero I'm I was supposed to
be speaking multiple times this month
it's all to zero my book tour not
happening and so all of this chaos I
look at my Toronto and salsa business
where we teach people how to dance salsa
the largest dance school in Canada maybe
North America for salsa dancing and shut
down zero nothing not happening right I
mean we can't have classes during
coronavirus people are not allowed to
touch so our business was shut down by
the government and that sucks it's easy
to get lost it's easy to get involved in
chaos and say oh my God this is It's All
Over everything's spiraling out of
control I can't control what happens
with coronavirus I can't control what's
happening with my students and whether
they're going to come back or not all
they can control is what I do all I can
control is how I show up every day I can
still make videos I can still plan I can
still create content I can still reach
out to my team and and ask how they're
doing and motivate and Inspire them I
could still do activities every day
where people get losses getting
overwhelmed by
just staying in their head saying oh my
God this is never going to work out I
don't know what to do and you're just
stuck in a spiral of thinking instead of
actually creating and getting lost in a
news cycle and seeing what's happening
and checking in 80 times a day to see
what the new death toll numbers are
coronavirus doesn't help you
there's one thing to be informed and and
it's great to be informed and you need
to make informed decisions amazing but
to be overwhelmed by it
to Cloud your thinking so that all
you're doing is thinking and not out of
action that just creates a really strong
negative cycle and spiral downwards
because when you're feeling out of
control the way out of it is to control
your actions again to control your
thinking again but if you're not
actually taking any action then you
never actually solve the problem and so
it's doing the best you can with what
you have I am still in control of my
time I can still wake up today and make
videos for you I can still wake up today
and do my Instagram stories I can still
wake up today and playing what we're
gonna do with my salsa business once we
get out of the coronavirus because this
is not going to last forever you can
still wake up today and choose to be
productive on the things that will best
Drive value for your business and for
your customers today rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
cup act on your ideas whenever I get an
idea I have to do something immediately
trust your ideas believe that they're
amazing and and manifest them into the
world I love it I'm not taking it from
the approach of I want this book to be a
new Times bestseller and I'm sitting
there visualizing my book being a New
York Times bestseller I'm not
visualizing myself being on Brendan
burchard's stage in Puerto Rico to a
couple thousand people uh that's not the
process that I typically go through
although I'm open to that maybe being a
mistake I don't know it's never really
felt like
it's worth it I don't know I'm sitting
there I've done it many times sitting
there visualizing I've never really felt
like that made a difference I'm open to
being totally wrong but how I do apply
it and it's massively seen an impact is
as soon as I get an idea for something
it's it's go time trust that Vision that
came to you trusted ideas in your head
and do something immediately about it
when I thought about the idea of having
a house of building a custom home I then
went off and built the 5 000 square foot
custom home like inside of the year we
had the whole thing done when I thought
about silly things like I thought about
having a mannequin I was watching Green
Arrow on TV and I loved how they all had
their their mannequins when they were in
their their layer or their realm they
had their outfits their costumes on a
mannequin and I thought I feel like I'm
I'm the Green Arrow I'm I got the Deep
Hood look I could be this is this is the
believe Arrow right uh I want a
mannequin too and then inside of a week
I had my own mannequin here and so it
may seem crazy it makes you wild but
that's how I tend to operate and I think
it's amazing right now I'm thinking
about doing a 30 day challenge on my
YouTube channel my main YouTube channel
where every day for the next 30 days I
have a series of videos to help you
build a better life so like 30 days to a
better life and it's going to be some of
our best work and I thought of the idea
and now immediately we're doing it and
so trust in the ideas that come to me
and then immediately creating them and I
guess manifesting them to the world I am
a thousand percent all in on
the sitting and visualizing the thing
that I want I have a struggle with and
I'm open to making it better and and
being changed we're faced the hardest
time with this is my health so I broke
my neck last year right I wore this for
for uh 60 days taking it off for 10
minutes a day that was it and I had a
concussion and I had two spots my neck
that were broken and I did some
meditation with a guy named Michael
Edwards who led me through this guided
meditation and he helped me and he was
doing it with me in person uh over over
the phone sending me videos and first
off was getting the concussion away
because I'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation I found really
helped the concussion the second part
was the visualization so I have a bone
in the back of my neck that broke off so
the big bone broke and is healed the
little bone just kind of broke off like
the tip like imagine I guess the
fingernail kind of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together and
and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because it's not a big
deal don't worry about it and Michael
was convinced that I could heal myself
and I could make that bone come back
together and so every uh night and every
morning I would do it twice a day
meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and and you know it
takes some you know hand sanitizer or uh
not hand sanitizer take some lotion and
and you know put it on my neck and just
as I'm to get more tactical like as I'm
doing it the the bones connecting I
talked to John Assaraf who was a another
you know legendary expert in this field
and he's he's fully convinced that it
can come back together through
visualization through meditation I
haven't done it yet I haven't I haven't
I haven't cracked a code on how to do it
I wish I did we did x-rays UH 60 days
later and it's still just as
disconnected it's still just it didn't
move a centimeter a millimeter closer
and that was honestly a little bit
uh you know negative or low or defeating
and and my motivation to do it as
intensely has has waned I haven't been
doing it twice a day every day I still
want to believe that is possible and I
still
kind of believe that it's possible and
maybe that's not enough maybe that's the
problem uh maybe the problem was I never
believed enough that it could happen and
that's why it didn't happen so I would I
would love for that to work I would love
for meditation to work I've meditated
with I don't know how many different
people so many different people I've
never really felt the benefit
um of having a meditation just feels
like I'm like I'm sitting down nothing
wrong with it just I don't feel extra
Clarity or anything coming out of the
meditation so
I believe that has worked for other
people I believe that it can work for me
I haven't found the path to make it work
so that's where I'm still struggling and
trying to improve and trying to get
better and reaching out to experts and
why I still feature people on my channel
because I'm trying to learn through the
process as well but but the idea of
taking the ideas that do come to you and
taking immediate action on them right
the last letters of of law of attraction
is action doing something trust in them
I think a thousand percent that can
serve you it has served me I know for
sure can serve you to learn to trust
your ideas and do something immediately
today about it and then build momentum
towards it and that big crazy thing you
have in your mind may not even be that
big and crazy once you actually start
taking some action on it and so that
part I'm a thousand percent down on and
you need to do something today in your
life to change
and the other side I'm totally open to
feedback suggestions on how I can get
better how you can get better
the biggest hack to stop caring about
other people's opinions to stop living
other people's version of your life and
to start actually feeling happy and
proud of yourself the biggest hack to
doing that is to figure out what you
stand for to figure out your single most
important core value I believe that
everybody has a single most important
core value and when you figure that out
it gives you a lot more clarity a lot
more Direction a lot more confidence and
allows you to start to to do things that
you never thought were possible all of a
sudden that idea that you've gotta oh my
gosh I could do this thing but then
never take an action on it things start
to happen for you because you have that
Clarity of value so I wrote two books on
this your one word and built to serve
and we go through the process of
figuring out your one word or your who
who are you what do you stand for what
is that single most important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out do I
just pick one at random do I just you
read a book like how do I actually
figure out what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math
is because they made you feel different
as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
Farr
but I'm far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely used
French and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of of uh
High School
and she would meet with me every week
Force before school started once a week
we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk about
life we talk about school we talk about
where I was at we talked about what was
on my mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more
that I that her belief in me created
more belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
[Music]
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask
another one you can look at is what was
your favorite movie growing up and why
so what's your favorite movie of all
time why there's so many movies that
you've watched most of them you don't
remember but there's one that that
sticks out that really stands out for
you in some in some way for some reason
my favorite movie is Seabiscuit it's
about this horse that is way too small
it's about this jockey that's way too
big it's about this owner that's
bankrupt and somehow they all find each
other and start winning a whole bunch of
races when when they they shouldn't be
you know and it's based off of a true
story and it ended up lifting a nation
that people love this Underdog Story and
it's a story of belief same thing
story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner
and helping not just each other believe
in themselves but also the nation
for the audience for the fans helping
them believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best for
I'm
even myself and my biggest problem is
still I need to believe in myself more
to get to the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value your who your one word
oh what you need right now
my biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who is just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her
we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like we're
having an impact on people whether the
closest people to us or to the world
but we're stuck and we're lost and we
need guidance and if you feel like you
have all these ideas but you don't know
how they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
is because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example
if I'm struggling to do something I'm
struggling to get on stage to speak I'm
struggling to turn on the camera to make
a video for you I'm struggling to launch
my next project you know I get an idea
and then I say oh but I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what do I really
need like what's the thing that's going
to turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more on yourself
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
report the video to get on stage it
launch that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance salsa his who
was belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not he in his goals and doing the
work is because he doesn't feel like he
belongs doesn't feel like he belongs to
himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
going too slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
and say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually feel that
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who watch your life change your
challenges don't only make you stronger
they allow you to serve better I think
the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
that I put in your way allow you to have
a a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor to build to serve you are
built to serve when you can connect the
challenge that you're going through as
something that's then going to inspire
and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
it's great for speaking but it sucks for
everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash uh we're we're next so we're
probably gonna get some crazy noise I
have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time and look
we're next you guys can see this is this
car wash we're next depending on how
long that guy ahead of us takes you
might you might see it in this video I
dealt with a lot of those mindset issues
those lack of belief issues those
worthiness issues and I I battled them
and I've been through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did and the path
can be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I've never been through anything
really physical you know I've I've
broken my toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run
and I was doing Instagram live at the
times like a light run fast Jog and I
like my toe was hurting so much and I
just kept powering through I didn't
later realize I broke my toe but that's
not really anything major right you know
if somebody's going through something
physical and major it's like you broke
your toe come on it's not a big deal and
so I never felt like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I'm having concussion I'm in
more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
it can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations if you want to make more
money you want to make big money you
have to start thinking on a bigger scale
and that might sound obvious as I say it
but recognizing your own limiting
thinking where you're playing small is
one of the most challenging things to do
I think in the world I am where I'm at
because I'm also I've thought big enough
but also I'm not at a higher level
because I'm not thinking bigger period
it's really hard and so here's a quick
example there was uh two days ago I was
talking to an entrepreneur friend of
mine and he's built he's built a decent
business inside of one year he's got a
quarter Million Dollar business right
that's pretty good business for for one
year and he went from
you know being let go from his job and
starting this company and now he's at a
quarter million in revenue and he
messages me just as a as a fun thing to
do and he's like hey I'm doing a points
run where should I go
it's okay if you could fly anywhere
where would you go on a points run like
what's the points run
and he said I'm I'm qualifying for uh
one of the airlines to get a certain
level a certain tier with them and I
need to get a certain number of points
so that I can qualify to get in and I
said oh I don't know I don't I pay zero
attention to that if you're thinking
about going somewhere
instead of flying this is how you
upgrade this is how you make more money
right it's upgrading the thinking he's
trying to solve the problem of I need to
get into the Points Club so that I can I
can get whatever marginal benefits from
being in that club
and I said you know what you should be
thinking of instead of flying economy to
some city that is however many miles
away you need to get your points what
you should be doing is thinking how do I
make it worth my time to fly somewhere
where I can afford to fly business class
and land a five-figure deal as a result
of being there
he's got
a couple clients right now that if he
could go and visit them we were just on
on a call and he's talking about how one
of his clients is having a hard time
figuring out a standard operating
procedure of how they should be applying
the knowledge he's given them and and
train their team on how to do it right
that that was a problem that just came
up for them it's like we love what
you're telling us we love your offering
we're having a hard time executing it
and making it standard procedure
the next call that he's doing with them
was going to be to train them and how to
do it great hey instead of thinking
about a points run how about you go fly
there
and say you know what I'll spend a day
with you
sitting down training you on how to do
this
this is a client that is already
mid-fight favorite client a year for him
that could easily become a low
six-figure client a year for him so he
could more than double the business
if they execute on his ideas right
because he's not in there doing all the
work but this could this could more than
double his business with this one client
with with no real extra added cost or
expense to him just pure income at the
top
so instead of hopping on the zoom call
with them and training them and going
back and forth on email how about you
fly there spend a day with them build
the relationship even deeper with them
because he's never actually met them in
person
and that way you you take your points
run you still get your points and
qualify for whatever discounts you get
and benefits you can fly business class
there have a much better experience and
end up doubling the business with your
client and getting an extra five six
figures as a result of it like this is
the upgrade in the thinking you want to
make bigger money you have to start
thinking about bigger thinking and I
fully acknowledge that I'm not thinking
big enough for where I want to go you
know every time I
I think I'm thinking big I'll watch a
Grant Cardone video or I'll watch an
Elon Musk video and Elon Musk is talking
about having a backup plan for the
planet that's why we're going to Mars I
watch a Steve Jobs video of taking a
dent in the universe and I realize oh my
gosh I'm thinking so small you know I'm
doing nothing not in a bad way in an
inspiring positive way to say man you
could be doing so much more come on man
let's go
so it's still my biggest problem too
it's the hardest thing to catch
because for him
and his environment and his friends and
how he grew up
a points run is is correct thinking you
know getting the discount codes is the
right thinking
the challenge with that is you're
spending time looking for the best deal
and looking to save a hundred dollars
here or a couple hundred dollars there
and you're using your mental energy up
on small problems
what my friend is doing is using his
mental energy up on trying to save a
couple thousand dollars when he could be
adding six figures to his business with
the same mental energy
now luckily you know he brought it up
and I was able to call him out on it and
and suggest a better path forward
if he hadn't it it was a joke I think
when he sent it like where would I where
should I go on a points run
felt like he expected the answer that I
gave him but I think the only way to to
get this is to be around the people who
can call it out in you either physically
I think that's the best the challenge is
it's as you as you get bigger as you
grow more there's fewer people who are
ahead of you who can push you
right there's fewer people who can look
at what you're doing and say hey this is
nothing play bigger in a loving way like
push you in a loving way as you climb
the ladder there's very there's fewer
and fewer people at the top of the
ladder who are ahead of you right and so
yes you want to give back and you want
to serve and as you learn you reach back
and you pull somebody else up to your
level but constantly finding somebody
that's why I love
um
I love Mastermind groups I love coaching
I love tapping into experts on different
topics because they pull me up uh even
if I'm an expert at something I want to
talk to my friends who are experts and
people who are ahead of me because they
push me to be better and if you don't
know those people yet
what are your options well you could
join group programs
right for example movement makers I love
my movement makers program it's 49 bucks
a month and we meet every two weeks and
you get to learn from me and there's
other amazing humans who are trying to
build up their platforms as well and
become thought leaders and experts but
if it's not my program there's tons of
other programs out there who do you
connect with who do you love who do you
look up to and you get a little bit of
you may not be able to afford to fly
there and meet them but you can learn
from them even in a group setting if you
can't afford that you know 49 bucks a
month or 97 bucks a month or whatever
the programs are is too much for you
then even the free content even even
what I'm doing even these videos here
you get a little bit from some super
successful person every time I make a
video if you even just consistently
watch those I've learned a ton from Elon
Musk and and uh Jeff Bezos and Steve
Jobs and people who I've never met
through my own videos and they push me
and they challenge me they can't
specifically call me out they can't say
hey Evan what you're doing right here
this thing that you're doing like the
points run is small right you shouldn't
be doing that but they can at least give
me encouragement and motivation in in
seeing what they're doing inspires me to
want to do something bigger focus on who
you are serving instead of who you're
not that one sentence is at the core of
how I've been able to stay so consistent
to keep making content to not give up to
not get too discouraged and to get back
up every single time and keep going
because I focus on who I am serving
instead of who I'm not
I just recently spoke at Brandon
burchard's influencer Summit and
I shared my graphic of how I've grown
over the years on my channel every time
I show that graph they always ask me how
did you keep going in in the first five
years when you had no subscribers when
you had no comments how did you keep
going
and how did you make so many videos how
did you not burn out how have you made
12 000 videos over 12 years how how do
you keep doing it and I don't think I'm
superhuman I don't think I'm I'm extra
special uh I think I had actually more
problems than most I'm I'm shy I'm
introverted I was afraid of the camera I
felt like only egotistical people put
themselves on camera and told their
story I had lots of limiting beliefs and
struggles in getting
my channel and just belief in myself to
put anything out there I hated my first
350 videos I couldn't watch anything
back totally embarrassed by everything I
made
uh and it was 750 videos before I
inspired myself before I finally liked
one of my own videos like you know what
I'm starting to get decent at this that
was a good video 750 videos in before I
did that so how how do you keep going
how does that make any sense
because I always focus on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't
most of us just focus on who we're not
serving think about your girl think
about if you've made any kind of content
you know at the beginning you get
nothing right there's no reaction
there's no comments and then maybe you
get one comment and then maybe you get
five comments or maybe you get 10 likes
or maybe you get however many views on
your videos right you got 100 views on
your video now that's kind of the
standard now if you get 20 views again
on a video oh that that doesn't feel so
good right or if you get a thousand
views on a video or 10 000 views on if
there are a hundred thousand views on a
video I remember the first time I got a
hundred thousand views on a video it's
like wow I've made it
foreign
and then it's easy to feel like oh the
next video got 10 of that and you feel
like oh I I suck it's not working
right
instead of focusing on that because
that's a losing game
focus on who you are helping and assume
that it is serving people
I've always felt I think some kind of
responsibility or
just gratitude that anybody would care
about what I had to say and that you
were spending your time with me I
remember my first speaking gig was at
the YMCA in Canada was at the YMCA and
three people showed up
you know three people showed up and I I
just did my best to give a great
experience to those three people
and then I kept doing it and and the
next time we had four and then we had
seven then we had 12 and then we had 15
and then we had 20 and then we outgrew
the space and so then uh I went to the
boardroom of a bank uh Royal Bank of
Canada and took over their boardroom at
night for entrepreneurs either free
events I was putting on just to help
entrepreneurs I had no business model or
pitch just serving and then we got too
big for the Royal Bank so then we went
to Indigo which was a bookstore it's
like a Barnes and Nobles of Canada we
had you know people coming out and then
more and more and more every every two
weeks I did it again and more people
came and at the at the height we had the
second most number of people to ever
show up at at the bookstore number one
was Sting when he launched the musician
sting when he launched his book he came
when he did a little concert and that
was the number one event in terms of
number of people that came out and the
second one was my little entrepreneur
speeches
[Laughter]
it's crazy
when you focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not it does a
couple of things okay
number one it makes you feel so much
better about what you're doing
it makes you feel so much better that
what you're doing matters right we all
want to feel like what we do matters and
if you're used to a thousand views on a
video and then you get 100 views on the
next one you feel like you don't matter
right you feel like you're losing your
value because it didn't reach as many
people don't think like that 100 people
saw it
be thankful and be grateful for the 100
people doesn't mean that you stop caring
about growth and Improvement right
somebody asked me about satisfaction and
happiness and they said I'm I'm always
always happy but I'm almost never
satisfied
I always want to be getting better to
grow to improve and it's more personal
thing if I want to put my best effort
out there today this video I want to be
one of my best videos ever and maybe
accomplish that maybe I don't but it's
the intent because I'm never satisfied
with where I'm at but I'm happy
I'm happy as a human because by putting
out great work and by paying attention
to who you are serving I think that's
the key to being happy to being
fulfilled to feeling like what you do
matters so it gives you that by focus on
who you are serving it gives you that
and number two
when you focus on the people who you are
serving here's a secret they take you to
the people who you're not serving yet
right if you love this video you might
share it with somebody
you might come back and watch another
video or maybe you share that video with
somebody
when you focus on loving on your
community it's that it's that double
whammy in a positive way of you feel so
good that what you do is having a
meaningful effect and when you love on
your customers when you love on your
audience
they're going to take you to more people
because they're going to feel the love
and they're going to spread it for you
you don't have to tell them to do it
they'll do it on their own
because
they get Good Vibes by being around you
even if it's just virtually
I think it's really critical
people are really struggling with mental
health
in creation right now in
entrepreneurship right now it's a giant
struggle and I see a lot of my
contemporaries a lot of people on
YouTube giving up after a couple months
saying I need a mental health break I'm
burnt out and I've made 12 000 videos
over 12 years and we're still going
and it's not again that I'm superhuman
it's just a shift I'm I'm focusing on
who I am serving and who I am helping
not all the things that I suck at and
how I'm not growing fast enough because
that game never ends right it's a
never-ending climb
so some years I do better than others
and some months I do better than others
and do I want to have bigger numbers of
course
but it's not the reason why I do what I
do
one other little trick that helps a lot
is
assume that for somebody
at least one person what you're going to
create today is gonna be life-changing
assume that for somebody at least one
person what you will create today will
be life-changing that if you're making
content and 100 people see your video
and you might think that's a failure
because you're used to a thousand views
on your video
that for one of those hundred people
it's a life-changing video
my hope my intention is that this video
today is a life-changing video for
somebody for for some of you watching
for most you watching maybe it's just
another good videos okay thank you good
good shot of espresso in the morning
here we go thank you awesome or you're
having breakfast or you're doing
something else you're driving in your
car on your way to work and you're
you're listening to me awesome amazing
but I hope
that for one person it's it's a
life-changing video it's finally going
to give you the permission to go off and
do the thing that you desperately want
to do that you know is in your heart and
has to come out I I just feel that and
I've seen it enough over the years of
people telling me
that my videos have had an impact on
them
only years later yesterday at Brandon
burchard's influencer event that I spoke
at people were commenting and then dming
me on Instagram and sharing stories of
I've been following you since whatever
year and this is the first time they're
ever telling me right they never left a
comment on a video they never message me
they never emailed me they never they
never tweeted they never sent anything
it's the first time I've ever seen their
name ever and they've been a hardcore
follower for a decade
and I've had a huge impact and I'm part
of their daily life and it's only now a
decade later that I'm finding out about
it
right
there are people who are like that for
you too
and we just assume that we don't matter
and we assume because you might get a
few less views on a video or post that
it's not having an impact and not having
a reach and then you take that person
and feel like you suck assume that it's
making an impact on somebody assume that
it's life-changing for somebody that you
are giving hope encouragement motivation
permission for somebody else to go and
become their best selves
when you tie your self-worth to the
results that you're getting
you ultimately are going to lose
because
have some days where you don't get
results
and it's going to defeat you it's going
to lead to stress it's going to lead to
anxiety it's going to lead to a while in
the quit it's going to lead the burnout
to fulfillment the key to momentum the
key to sustained activity and the key to
actually loving the work that you're
doing
is reminding yourself
a focus on the people that you are
serving instead of the ones that you
aren't
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there I think we constantly go through
this I I recently went through this late
last year where I got invited to speak
at Brendan burchard's event and a couple
thousand people in the room and up until
that point I hadn't done a big speaking
event